freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ist ein sehr besonderes video
heute hat nämlich in der kölner
innenstadt ein komplett veganer burger
king auf gemacht das gibt es nur in
dieser woche und nur in köln so wir sind
jetzt in köln am neumarkt angekommen war
weiß auch da und es ist nicht mehr weit
dann bestellen wir alles schon sehr
gespannt sein guck mal direkt neben fünf
gekommen um die ecke da ist das objekt
der begierde der vegane burger king
seien keine großen schlange zu sein oder
sehr gut
ein bild aus also sie haben sie echt
mühe gegeben mit der außenansicht ein
bisschen schlange ist schon am start war
lange schon nicht hier ja man schon
außer hier termin ist wo man bestellen
kann
aber wir warten jetzt mal ab 1 also wir
das ding ist ich glaube es können
eigentlich nicht super viele sachen sein
aber sarah dem ich habe schon mal auch
anderen screen schaut so aus als wäre
schon relativ viel am start aber wir
nehmen halt komplette karte deshalb
schauen wir mal
ok steht ja wir probieren das jetzt
einfach mal aus wir nehmen jetzt mal
einfach einmal alles wir nehmen aber ich
war so was wenn es uns darüber würden
die welt in ein fangnetz sind die auch
begann
effizienz sie kann nicht egal sein aber
sie zeigt merkel muss ja auch begraben
sein
alle berge okay wir müssen nur die
burger fest dass von gerade auch wieder
raus der leute ist eine echte nicht
damit gerechnet wir haben einfach eine
option
sportlich ist alles einmal anklicken und
in den blogs und chats fördert ihre
absicht der vegan und jetzt nur diese
woche hier also wird auf jeden fall
werde ich freue mich drauf aber wirklich
komplett alles einmal in den warenkorb
bauen wenn es jetzt aber es war wie so
ein big gegen den speed king und viking
xxl da habe ich halt nur eingenommen
aber komplett liberalisiert placebase dh
post jetzt 38 euro geht die bestellung
auf und ich bin sehr gespannt
die führte beck also manchmal so super
viel aber man trotzdem bürger die es
sonst woanders nicht gibt und ich bin
sehr gespannt auf den text elf artikeln
haben jetzt bestellt mit hessen ist
jetzt ganz gemütlich im büro
es kommt also leute es ist zeit mit dem
test haben ist dass in dieser ebenso
youtube heute wahrscheinlich auch nach
dem motto so ökologie dies dass annas
ich möchte eines klarstellen ist sind
nur glaube ich bei manchen produkten wie
pettys vegan also quasi zwei so sachen
wie diesen mozzarella ding und so es
hallt durch den mozzarella noch braucht
und halt keinen veganer mozzarella lass
mir selbst erst mal wir stellen gerade
aufgefallen aber hier haben wir auf
jeden fall unsere elf bürger und lassen
uns noch einfach alles auspacken
oha erst mal nachzählen das auch alles
am start ist
wir haben neun produkte bekommen und
haben 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 bestellt
die haben uns auch diesen geilen nicht
gegeben denn mit den lack mit christi
hey das ist super weg das kann nicht
dein ernst sein long ghriskey euro 50
jetzt mal ehrlich leute das ist richtig
weg womit fangen wir an unser review mit
dem extra lang chili cheese wir müssen
jetzt kurz dazu sagen wir haben extra
nicht gefrühstückt wir haben jetzt 13
uhr 30 damit wir uns hier durchfahren
können und wir checken als erstes mal
den chili cheeseburger aus extra
ok also das sind schon mal die veganen
tätig sie sind auf jeden fall neu also
diese kleinen dünnen sind neu so dass du
das gab es bisher bei birkin noch nicht
also dass man schon schmecken
sehr stabil also hier wirklich sehr leid
weil chili und käse dominieren das ganze
so ne also dadurch will jetzt nicht
sagen das ist nicht da ist aber dadurch
würde auch ein weniger vorhandener
fleischgeschmack nicht aufhellen aber
wer hat schon ein besonderes album
genauso wie gestern bei der veganen ball
wir haben gestern auch so eine vegane
polonaise mit beyond mitgekauft
verbrauch so einen leichten
eigengeschmack das wird wahrscheinlich
auch ersten proteine sein textur mäßig
weil es gibt schon leute die sich
darüber lustig machen dass in jedem
video textur sage textur mäßig ist das
genauso wir bewerten die bürger auf
einer skala von 0 bis 10 ganz egal ob
wir jetzt vegane tätig sind oder nicht
und der erste bürgerkrieg von uns acht
von zehn punkten also selten ist auch
wenn ich die wachs gut dass du da bist
ich wollte gerade ein gutes bild zeigen
das gute bild ist das mein handy haben
dafür mein handy ich weiß was hier
gerade denkt ihr denkt wahrscheinlich um
mein gott macht hat das handy von
sebastian zerstört er muss jetzt seinen
youtube channel verkaufen um die
reparatur bezahlen zu können aber nein
auch wenn das vielleicht vor kurzem noch
so gewesen wäre
ich benutze jetzt die klage der für mich
meine verträge optimiert so auch mein
privathaftpflichtversicherung die für
sowas verantwortlich ist und stellt für
mich kontinuierlich welche versicherung
ich persönlich brauche das neueste daran
ist dass clark ein digitaler
versicherungsmanager ist das heißt alles
passiert auf eurem smartphone mit
antworten haben ja nicht den film zum
makler zu gehen war wie zu müssen oder
so sondern ihr könnt wirklich alles
innerhalb ihrer komfortzone auf dem
handy machen und ich weiß dass das thema
versicherung nicht super interessant ist
aber genau darum geht es ja bei klagt
die gucken sich für euch an was ihr
braucht und helfen euch das beste
auszuwählen und das ganze funktioniert
indem klagt die tarife von über 160
versicherungsanbietern vergleicht und
den besten für euch aus wählt also alles
auf dem handy kein stress mit papierkram
keine wartezeit und vor allem keine
kopfschmerzen mehr mit versicherungs
check up und geht am besten meint ein
oder nutzen meinen link und erhaltet bis
zu 45 euro amazon gutscheine indem ihr
einfach nur eure bestehenden
versicherung dort hochladen
kein problem ist ich meine
haftpflichtversicherung die ich mit
clark optimiert habe alter fokus
womit machen wir weiter mich reizt
tatsächlich dieser woche aber ich habe
noch nie im red bull wie kay gegessen
sie mal ab nach den ersten text ist aber
dann war da noch irgendwas sagt oder
schon richtig erkannt
ich frage mich wie die das schaffen dass
der whopper so einen starken
eigengeschmack hat weil eigentlich ist
ja der volle standard bürger so oder so
schmeckt richtig gut neun von zehn okay
du hast den nächsten auswählen langsam
wird schon ein bisschen schwer aber wir
schaffen das das ist wahrscheinlich
dieser mozzarella kinn oder ich bin nur
gespannt ob wir es auch diese
superdünnen fertigt von baden im
dreikampf eigentlich ist ja so ein
premium bürgern dass wir nicht irgendwie
wissen durch das dass du über spricht
sich schon ein bisschen komisch oder
sondern mal ehrlich steht einfach
komplett über ist es halt alles nicht
optimiert für ein restaurant das muss
man sich aber auch gegen die produktion
und sowas kann ja nicht einfach alles
machen für ein kleines restaurant in der
kölner innenstadt gelegen dass trotzdem
also ein bisschen mit also wir halbieren
das war jetzt auch der teuerste bürger
auf der karte wir probieren in dem
gesamtkonzept fällt am meisten auf das
kein fleisch drin ist oder also das ist
ein gleich los partie ist findest du
nicht in die soße ist halt irgendwie
mega dominante pestel mäßig kennt jemand
der sagen würde das fest durch mir zu
fruchtig nein spaß noch freund an dieser
stelle also es ist auf jeden fall ein
bisschen dominant ist sehr süß 7 jetzt
bin ich vorn mit auswählen ich habe bloß
woche hatten wir so ähnlich schon ich
hab doch auf den hamburger weil der ist
ja komplett vegan jetzt eigentlich oder
da ist in okka chubb drauf keine mio
ansonsten gewürzgurke paar zwiebelchen
und das vegane partie also hier haben
wir wirklich komplett veganen bürger
er sieht im vergleich zu dem was wir
sonst schon so hat ein bisschen mickrig
aus also da nari jetzt ist der wahre
test wie sich das vegane fleisch bei
burger king schlägt also ich finde in
diesem burger fällt bisher am meisten
auf das ist kein richtiges fleisch ist
einfach so wenig aus und rum ist
nichtsdestotrotz schon eigentlich echt
eine alternative nur muss man sagen
hamburger an sich sind halt natürlich
keine zehn von zehn jetzt weniger
spannend was wir dem geben
du darfst du nicht nur für huth
das hier ist das ist der ist der begann
mario drauf
so sieht er aus die pace schicken wir
jetzt habe ich schon mal probiert auch
mal was anderes als einfach ein stern
ist wieder normal also das ist schon
lange gute veganer chicken nuggets gibt
ist ja glaub ich bekannt aber dieser
burger ist einfach genau wieder mit
echtem schicken ich habe meine bewertung
überlegt du auch 9,5 von 10
ich bin wieder dran mit auswählen und
ich nehme den big thing xxl steht drauf
aber ich glaube ich normal angenommen
auch einen bogey das ist endlich mal
salat ja auch einer der bürger die ich
gerne mag ich habe mich früher immer
sehr gefreut wenn der bekämpfung des
monats war in meiner mittagspause gab es
irgendwie klum mit dem crispy chicken
immer für zwei euro ja ja ständig ein
keine zeit und derzeit nicht gehabt und
wir schauen mal rein
ok krass keine unterschiede 32 18 19
das ist ein schlachtfeld gleicht wenn
wir am ende doch froh sein dass wir uns
einfach drei bürger die wir bezahlt
haben sich mit gegeben habe also da wie
seine auswahl
das ist das noch mal ich weiß es selbst
nicht das kann gut sein dürfte relativ
ähnlich dem exchange sein
trotzdem probieren natürlich knallen
irgendwie heute ich weiß nicht mehr
genau was sich gegeben habe aber ich
weiß was ich dem gehen würden 19
wir sind fast durch ich glaube dass hier
ist der cheeseburger wer mir grad eben
beim hamburger gesehen dass der relativ
schlecht verfahren bin gespannt ob der
käse das ganze vielleicht ein bisschen
rausreißen kann ja gut ich finde es echt
krass
der käse macht das irgendwie der täuscht
darüber hinweg dass das können
48 schade dass jetzt diesen ja wirklich
wir haben uns nämlich davor darüber und
haben gemeinsam ihr eigentlich sind die
ganze produkte ja nicht wirklich neu
sondern es ist so ein veganes partie das
kleine was neues offen ist und dieser
externen christi oder wie es der sohn
los schicken sein sollte nicht einfach
nicht gegeben und das war durch komplett
neu bin ich loki bisschen nett aber was
soll's wir kommen zum finale wir haben
nicht groß was zu entscheiden der rebel
bobber den kensington ich bin trotzdem
gespannt
von diesem rebel bobber kam nämlich
glaube ich auch dass patti was bei den
mozzarella allerdings kommen also halt
eigentlich auch komplett vegan aus dem
ios kann ich text nicht wieso schaffen
wie es nicht eine vegane macht nur
einfach draußen zu machen also ihr kennt
ja auch für mich zum beispiel kochen hat
er dann sehr krasse veganer mario
versteht nicht warum barocken die nicht
einfach auch ein kauf ich würde lügen
wenn ich sage dass ich mich auch ein
bisschen freude das wird jetzt durch
sind weil es war auf jeden fall ne
kranke fressorgien letzter wissen 3218
von zehn leute es war die schlacht gab
es geschafft bin ein bisschen enttäuscht
wie gesagt dass jetzt am ende halb so
wild ich hoffe ihr konnte trotzdem
intertainment story dass diese eine
bürger nicht dabei war und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten video wieder persönlicher
koch diesen sonntag mit papa platte also
auf jeden fall einschalten besser